Ok Cyprien t'es allé beaucoup trop loin en me clashant
Après réflexion moi et ma communautés on a décidé de te répondre.
Par contre je vais pas mettre ton beat vénère ils vont flipper .
J'vais mettre un truc qui leur parle
Ouè vazy PewDiePie (sub2pewds)
Ta gueule toi
Ton son comme une merde
c'etait un tube si t'etais pas dessus
T'es un adulte qui parle de trucs de jeunes
pour faire des vues
t’es comme facebook
tout l’monde s’en bat les couilles de toi
l’ferai plus de vues qu’tes court métrage
juste en filmants mes doigts
tu fais peine à voir
tu t’habilles comme un comptable
j’suis passé devant une maison de retraite
ils t’attendent pour le scrabble
Mettre des perruques pour imiter des gens
c’est juste pas marrant
Bonjour c'est cyprien et revenons sur l'épisode des anges de la téleréalité
Ah nan arrêtez les enfants arrêtez
Nannnnnnn
Nan c'est bad buzz ça putain
nannn
bad buzz la